"The Batman" is barely out in theaters worldwide,
and people are already fan-casting their dream
follow-up.
A sequel to "The Batman" hasn't officially
been announced as of the making of this video.
That said, the film teases more adventures
from the Dark Knight and his rogues' gallery
of foes moving forward.
Furthermore, producer Dylan Clark has a timeframe
in mind for the seemingly inevitable follow-up
to Matt Reeves' gritty blockbuster, and Warner
Bros. intends to give one of the movie's villains
his very own spin-off series.
All in all, it seems that the studio heads
and filmmakers have high hopes for this iteration
of the "Batman" franchise.
Of course, even the slightest possibility
of a sequel to "The Batman" is enough of a
reason to get fans talking about the characters
they'd like to see make an appearance down
the line.
Penguin, the Riddler, and the Joker have all
had time in the spotlight in recent years.
But the "Batman" vault boasts a wide array
of memorable baddies, many of whom have arguably
been overlooked, underserved, or flat-out
ignored in the live-action movies.
Gotham's Caped Crusader has a long history
with Mr. Freeze that's barely been explored
in the films, and many fans would no doubt
love to see a serious exploration of that
conflict now that they've had time to recover
from Arnold Schwarzenegger's ill-fated turn
as the character in 1997's "Batman & Robin."
"What killed the dinosaurs?
The ice age!"
It remains to be seen if "The Batman" filmmakers
include Mr. Freeze in a future project.
Numerous "Batman" fans on social media have
been calling for Mr. Freeze to appear in the
sequel to Matt Reeves' film, causing the character
to trend online in the process.
Meanwhile, over on Instagram, artist Mizuri
has shown how the iconic villain could look
if he were to be portrayed by English actor
Mark Strong.
The chilling illustration depicts Strong with
icy white skin, sporting a pair of glasses
that accentuate Freeze's red eyes.
The character's trademark black suit is also
on display, giving him an imposing and muscular
appearance.
The image is capped off with blue hues which
really enhance the freezing factor that fans
expect to be associated with this particular
villain.
The picture is much scarier than Arnold Schwarzenegger's
version of the character from "Batman & Robin,"
and some of Mizuri's followers support the
idea of seeing Strong cast as a formidable
foe.
One commenter wrote,
"Mark as Freeze would be awesome.
I always thought he suited the role."
Elsewhere, some followers revealed how they'd
like to see Mr. Freeze used in the sequel.
One user wrote,
"I really love how they portrayed his character
in the Arkham games and I really want to see
that version in a live-action film."
Mark Strong is no stranger to comic book movie
roles, having previously starred in Matthew
Vaughn's "Kingsman: The Secret Service" and
the sequel "Kingsman: The Golden Circle,"
as well as "Kick-Ass."
He's also no stranger to the DC Universe,
having appeared in "Green Lantern" and "Shazam!."
Back when the movie was in pre-production,
he was also heavily rumored to be in the running
for the role of Lex Luthor in "Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice," so it's understandable why
superhero fans continue to dream cast the
Englishman as their favorite characters.
But what are the possibilities of Strong gracing
the sequel to "The Batman?"
There is no record of Strong stating his interest
in the role.
Furthermore, he appears to be taking a break
from DC flicks for now.
The actor previously revealed that he will
not be in "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods," but could he be deceiving
us?
Dr. Thaddeus Sivana's burgeoning alliance
with Mister Mind following the events of the
first film suggests that he has unfinished
business in this franchise after all.
"What in God's name?"
"I made the gods, Doctor – not the other
way around."
The filmmakers might opt to catch up with
Strong's evil scientist and his quest to take
over the Seven Realms down the line.
That would give him a window to play Freeze,
right?
Additionally, "The Batman" isn't part of the
same cinematic universe as "Shazam!."
Theoretically, that would mean that Strong
could play the Gotham City menace without
having to worry about crossing paths with
his "Shazam!"
antagonist.
It's certainly an idea worth considering.
"The Iceman cometh!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.